[Música]
economía en directo América de Francia
24 nuevamente en el estudio Daniela
Blandón Daniela y seguimos con la lo que
va a hacer seguramente la noticia del
día en términos económicos y y ese que
la economía del mundo se mueve al ritmo
de Estados Unidos por qué Porque ya
tenemos el dato de inflación de ese país
ya lo tenemos Sí señor el departamento
de trabajo Raúl reveló que la inflación
interanual en julio fue del
8,5%. y si se compara Julio con junio
anterior prácticamente no hubo cambios
como no ocurría hace dos años que no
haya cambio entre un mes y el otro esto
es una buena noticia relativamente para
el mercado que esperaba una
desaceleración de este índice de precios
después de que un mes antes es decir en
junio anotar a una alza interanual del
9,1% quiere decir que se está
desacelerando desde su nivel más alto en
cuatro décadas esto les dio un ligero
descanso a los consumidores
especialmente por la caída en el precio
de la gasolina
lo que sí se ha mantenido el alza son
los precios de otros rubros como
alimentos los alquileres los automóviles
también los servicios médicos por lo que
el mercado prefiere no cantar Victoria
temprano Aunque hay un leve respiro como
lo decimos la meta de la reserva Federal
es mantener la inflación en alrededor
del 2% anual estamos en más del 8% de
todas maneras hay una brecha muy alta
por eso viene subiendo las tasas de
interés para desincentivar precisamente
el consumo y enfriar la economía Dani
ante todo esto por supuesto le pregunto
cómo están Entonces los indicadores
económicos Cómo se está moviendo ya los
mercados internacionales sobre todo el
de Estados Unidos no sé si hay datos
salieron hace tres minutos también los
datos de Wall Street abrió fuertemente
al alza especialmente el índice nasdaq
tecnológico que es uno de los que ha
sido más golpeados con tasas de interés
abrió con un 2% de ganancia ese índice
específicamente Y esto es porque la
inflación salió mejor de lo esperado es
alta pero es mejor Y eso qué quiere
decir que algunos en el mercado podrían
estar reduciendo sus apuestas hacia
nuevas salsas de las tasas de interés
Qué quiere decir esto también antes del
dato casi un 70% del mercado esperaba un
alza de 75 puntos básicos en la próxima
reunión de la reserva Federal ahora
solamente un 33% Espera que vaya a ver
ese aumento según la agencia routers las
acciones europeas también reaccionan en
positivo las asiáticas si estaban más
pesimistas cerraron en rojo antes de que
se conociera toda esta información y
seguimos en Europa Daniela porque
Alemania va a lanzar un paquete
económico para precisamente combatir la
inflación una inflación en Raúl que
supera el 7% y que está en sus niveles
más altos en 40 años así como también en
Estados Unidos el gobierno lanzó un
primer plan a un primer paquete
económico a comienzos de este año este
en ese momento incluía una reducción del
impuesto sobre el combustible y un pase
de transporte válido en toda Alemania a
un precio de solo 9 € al mes durante
junio julio y agosto ahora está
anunciando un nuevo plan dirigido a
disminuir el efecto de un fenómeno
conocido como Cold progression que se
refiere a que la gente como recibe
aumentos salariales para combatir la
inflación también tiene una mayor carga
fiscal
dice
estas medidas que pretenden compensar
este fenómeno cuentan con una
financiación pública de 10.000 millones
de euros y por tanto evitarían una
subida de impuestos si se aprobara esta
ley de compensación de la inflación se
beneficiarían 48 millones de personas y
de Alemania nos vamos hasta Asia vamos a
hacer un repaso por los resultados
empresariales de empresariales de dos
grandes firmas japonesas Dani Sí señor
antes de decirles los nombres le voy a
decir que tienen en común que ambas usan
semiconductores para su actividad y
tienen de diferente que mientras que uno
vivió un difícil segundo trimestre la
otra sí salió a flote estamos hablando
del fabricante de autos Honda cuyas
ganancias del trimestre terminado en
junio cayeron 33% sus ingresos lo
hicieron en 7%. esto debido a la escasez
mundial de chips los bloqueos
relacionados con la pandemia en China y
también el aumento de Los costos de las
materias primas esta escasez no
solamente afecta a esta compañía también
lo ha hecho con todos los fabricantes de
automóviles del mundo a pesar de que hoy
en día hay una fuerte demanda lo
contrario ocurre con Toshiba que aumentó
sus ganancias en 44% Y es que la
rentabilidad mejoro en su división
especialmente de dispositivos
electrónicos Toshiba recordemos fabrica
algunos tipos de semiconductores Aunque
necesita adquirir otros pero a quienes
fabrican dispositivos electrónicos más
pequeños se les ha hecho más fácil
acceder a ellos que a las compañías
automotrices porque Raúl porque
prefieren venderlos es mucho más fácil
vendérselos y le sacan una mejor
rentabilidad Dani cifra del día que nos
trae hoy Bueno de un tema que nos gusta
mucho que es y la Moss me encanta y lo
más que ha pasado entonces con esta
novela pero yo creo que vamos a hablar
no de Twitter sino de tesla nosotras
bueno Twitter no es compañía eh la que
es realmente su compañía Perdón que
ellos Sí ya emocionó
6.500 millones de eso es lo que ha
vendido de acciones de tesla y los que
en los últimos tres días no se sabe para
qué pero algunos dicen que es por si de
pronto llegar a perder el juicio contra
Twitter que lo obligaría por supuesto
como le hemos dicho aquí a pagar esos
44.000 millones de dólares Dani como
siempre Muchísimas gracias por toda la
información económica pasamos a salud y
saludamos a Marina